hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender's
woods okay we just entered the mansion
so oh that's a lovely painting aren't so
I'm assuming he's still on my ass this
place is a dead end there's no one here
and there's no working phone god dammit
I'm practically trapped in this forest
tried to get over the fence on the way
to the mansion but that creature
immediately appeared on the other side
waiting for me it's everywhere and it
will not let me escape I constantly
looked back to see if it's there it also
seems that the more I look at it the
more painful my headache becomes what
the hell is happening to me for [ __ ]
sake I can't hide anymore and I will
kill this thing going to the sawmill
there's gonna be some kind of weapon or
the chainsaw at least I'll kill that
abomination Obama in the nation even if
it's the last thing I ever do okay I
wonder what happened to that Cody guy
if you survive this nightmare um no go
uh oh come on the basement why do I need
to go down to the basement huh oh you
are one creepy crying kid okay kind of
cry fear style room entering OH
Oh No Oh
okay that was that's no good that's no
good at all I don't like this place it
just has to be so mansion II with all
its rooms and whatnot
most of our hand I need to put these on
the clock
not that clock the clock downstairs on
this tick tocking okay got it
is he in this house is he in here with
me is he in here with me my god oh
that's just two people they're wrestling
that wrestling kiddos what the hell is
that sound I don't want to know uh-huh
this is crap here over again ha oh god
what is wrong with this place that is so
freaky oh god it's so weird
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no aah
I don't like this place I don't like
this place Adalind at all at all at all
at all at all
a tall hat all Hetal
huh oh the basement door oh no my head
what the hell is happening to me is that
creature from the forest affecting my
mind uh yeah but yes oh did it progress
save I don't know I don't know I don't
know it's gonna make down here Slendy
time they putting you and your gigantic
nipples
I know you're kind of sensitive on that
regard oh god water never girl is that I
didn't read that what that say guys I
didn't read it
I'm a baby found a heavy hammer this
will help me get to the sawmill okay why
how the booze can I drink that please
fill the need for alcohol
I'm a baby I'm a big whiny baby
oh no how do I get to this sawmill oh
where Z where Z I was at him
ah damn like that hey back back you dude
I got a tree behind you and me
Oh head pounding pounding is on ha ha ha
come on behind the tree hey bladder day
hey come on honey now hey got ya bye
you do kiss me Bridgers our sawmill in
sawmill yeah do it do it do it
I'm in here aah Oh got you behind a
corner a solid wall with that what does
that do
what I'm not gonna go in there nice tie
yeah continue okay so I just got to run
faster than a sawmill and then go in and
not out it is important out is bad
oh no I musta reason you got me probably
was because I'm scaring out here the
zombie thumps owe me something
don't be something at me I don't need
the company sawmill go snack it with my
ham are ya
oh no he's here
oh hello hi goodbye
oh what's that there oh ah this isn't
better this is this is actually much
worse I'm guessing Balzac generator need
to get some fuel for the generator work
why do I need to do this why why do i
why did I suddenly give myself an
objective like this how does this help
me like to the lock need to turn the
power mr oh come on
strong and brave and tough that's right
I remember
I'm markiplier steered am i right hi
it's awful Kingdom I'm markiplier the
bravest let's player on YouTube right
gang right yeah
ain't nothing gonna get in my way I am
so tough so I'm fine
he's inside oh I read that one I read
that right
kurchuk right
the lights and I get some freaking light
in here please oh god where's this
batteries oh oh the map shows where the
keys it's in the house huh that means I
have to go back I don't wanna I don't
wanna I don't wanna huh good you
probably saved proof Raja Raja this is
the house where I my house is or is that
where I need a key to okay the key to
that door mother [ __ ] okay I got to go
back we gotta go back what's wait hang
on what's down here
not that I wanted nothing nothing just
gotta get out of here ah to get out
can't seeing all these noises in my head
which way do I go
I think I need to go out the back of
this thing guy I can't hear a thing
shrink down the volume for you guys gels
ah oh my god oh I'm so slow hi
about the mobile phone
I highly doubt that I will
locked from the other side fantastical
oh I'm I've owned a boat phone
my mom imon don't know where I'm going
I'm lost in the woods this seems
familiar
I'm innocent on my earlier playthroughs
of slender the eight pages
hi Mon I remember this
and okay I need to be getting a little
bit away from him
on the Rodian
crap I just wanted to make
ah cards mutters it's this way but it's
not supposed to be consummated supposed
to be away
Oh
I need to get two of
[ __ ]
Wow
Hill this way maybe this way think this
way there was a cave and there was a
house he's back there
those at a bonobo cave must be that way
in the house
I'm guessing I don't know
okay what does that say
I don't know
is this way
gotta be
it's got to be right
process of elimination man
process of elimination yeah yeah yeah No
behind behind behind up I got it I got
blocked off
okay enough with the heart Gumby
please I know he's behind there I know
he is fine now Oh balls I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead oh no progress
saving I'm just dead I'm dead I'm so
dead
I'm so dead I'm so dead once again got
to get back to the sawmill I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead
Oh
I mean f off lending junior for it's
awesome nipples you go hey go
I gotta take this back to the song
place I need to go correct
correct I don't know
I don't know I think I got it I think I
got it kill me sunny go back I say my
progress you dick you dick run run don't
look back
huh Oh God hey you see the remains of
Cody alone oh okay here are the eight
pages kind of different pages of time
button do not slow down closer than you
think
did he draw these probably like bullet
holes in the wall or something I don't
know
oh boy all right let's move on
moving save please save save save
something a gun no way no way no give me
a freaking gun please borrow saved okay
I got some bullet for you go man
come on oh wow wait go shut up
I guess I'm not supposed to shoot him
okay so don't go that way go this way I
don't even know what I'm going for
I don't even know how to shoot I don't
know which way I'm going
I really really
don't know
no damn c'mere
maybe I need to go to the cave the cave
old lamb lamb lamb lamb a lamb called
the cables behind us no the gate was
this way please
to death off
gave this way
Oh
this isn't anything is it nothing
nothing nothing here
I went the wrong way
mobile
oh okay all right
oh I'm a lot of time for this one so
I've had about enough of that so you
guys have any suggestions for what I'm
supposed to do please let me know in the
comments below if I'm supposed to shoot
him or I'm just want to go somewhere so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye